well what uh initially
we got reports at approximately 11 51
uh last night that there was a fire at
an apartment complex
the initial response was a first alarm
upon arrival they saw as they were
approaching
they saw flames in their eyes and they
immediately called a second alarm fire
once they got on scene they could tell
that it
was mostly on the left side of the
complex
and with the wind direction it was
starting to blow i'm sorry not the west
side the north side
starting to blow to the south side
at that point they started establishing
water lines in a defensive perimeter
because what was burned was burned
they're trying to stop
prevent anything else from burning
while they were trying to suppress the
fire they started getting reports
of exposure fires downwind so
a third alarm was dispatched and they
took care of that
they did an amazing job of canvassing
the neighborhoods
putting out multiple tree fires dumpster
fires
keeping any other residents from
catching fire
the apartment complex just west has
sustained some fire damage just from the
heat
it's they call the knock down at i
i can't remember what time this morning
sorry it's in the press release
but uh they're still on scene because we
have spot fires and it's not safe for
them to go in yet to confirm to go up to
those spot fires and put them all out so
once that has been uh deemed safe
they'll go in and start putting out the
spark fires
no no our firing guest
investigation team is on scene right now
they
all they have is that it traveled from
the north to the south side
they're attempting to get footage from
uh local businesses
uh camera footage to see if maybe it can
indicate
you know what started it and how it
started i did see there's some
security cameras on the company
yeah they'll be speaking with them also
they're going to gather
all the footage they can and go through
it atf
the atf is here assisting with the
investigation
and at this point they are debating on
whether or not to call their national
response team
that will that decision will be made if
they don't see anything in the video
footage that they gather does the atf
always respond or is there a reason why
yeah on any uh on any residence fire
they it's it's a normal protocol for
them to
respond and most of the times they don't
even you know need to be there
but they they go as protocol just in
case something
comes up how about protecting the homes
yeah so as i stated before the first two
alarms initially set up
to put out the fire but they were
getting the reports
of embers they could see the ambers
going then they started getting reports
that third alarm was dispatched and
most of those units were assigned to
canvas the neighborhoods and
uh downwind and they did find a couple
tree fires and some dumpster fires
at this point no but that that is always
a possibility
uh so they'll be trying to get in
touch with anyone they can to see if
they have any of the homeless
populations
if they have any indication what might
happen
i have not uh i have not heard that i
wasn't aware of that information
how does this fire compare to others
well there's there's a couple factors
here that really let this fire get going
one it's in the construction phase so we
had exposed
wood exposed combustibles two
is the the wind the wind
fueled the fire and it pushed the fire
so
it intensified the heat and also pushed
it to the south
a couple weeks ago and there was one six
months ago
no not that i'm aware of in fact uh
i don't remember the last construction
fire like this we've had uh
there it's not very often because
security like you said the fence there's
usually fencing around it there's
usually security security cameras
so uh that that's not common and it
hasn't
it hasn't been a trend
i i do not know i know metro was called
to assist with traffic control and i
think they assisted with some
evacuation on the south end and these
apartments over here
facing the fire but i couldn't give you
exact numbers
and the american red cross was called
in the anticipation that we would have
displaced people
but that is not the case we do have some
fire damage but no one has been
displaced
uh well i'm sure they just because
they're trying to get to many
people as possible they're just knocking
on the door telling people to evacuate
they don't stay and make sure they
evacuate because then they can't
they can't move forward and tell
everybody else
no there were no residences no buildings
caught fire
there was embers on top of roofs
uh they did not catch fire and the crews
were on scene like i said they were
they were downwind making sure that any
embers that landed
didn't cause further damage
so there was obviously
i i i know the utilities were secured
but i actually asked on scene cruz this
morning
if there there was gas to the property
he said the utilities were secured
in reference to that question so they're
i there i think there was gas but i
can't give you a definitive answer
one last thing do you have a message to
anybody
i don't know if it's suspicious or
anything but if you give any suggestions
like hey do you need this information do
you have any
yeah if you uh if you have any
information uh we would uh
appreciate a phone call you can call
one 702-455-7311 that's our main number
and they will put you
in touch with the investigations
division
still accurate to say 206 units the
project was 50 yeah
i didn't hear how done it was and i
don't know how many units
i do know that this is going to be a
total loss
uh they're estimating the value between
25 up to
30 million uh dollars because they're
going to have to start all over
tear it down and then rebuild was this
insured
um i'm assuming i couldn't speak for the
developing company but i would assume so
that